>>It's not an "s", it sounds
like it, what does it sound like?
>>"C"?
>>There you go.
>>Donna Barrier: The way we
deliver RTI has everything to do
with the end results that we've
seen for student achievement.
Today there is a small discrepancy
between our highest achieving students
and our lowest achieving students.
>>Beth Rickerman: Our overall vision
and mission would be for every child
to experience success at their
level, whatever that level may be.
>>Amanda Kuhlman: RTI is "response
to intervention", it's making sure
that every child receives the support
that he or she needs at any given time
and that might change weekly.
>>Mary Krenke: It's a team
atmosphere and over these past years
with the RTI the walls have come
down, we're all in it together.
>>Teacher: I could take
some of your kids to rea--
just for the "Read Naturally" part
if your groups are too big, you know?
>>Donna Barrier: Through
the years we moved
from being segmented individual
classrooms to what you see today.
Everything is done by
the grade-level team.
When we first started moving students
about in the building some parents
had a few questions, "You mean,
my child won't be in
one classroom all day?"
No, we're going to try to provide
more targeted instruction working
with them in small groups.
>>The rest of my friends
are gonna join me.
Grab a stool and a pencil.
Take a look at the first problem.
>>Mary Krenke: The difference is
between the tiers, tier one, tier two,
and tier three is tier one
is the general population,
universal instruction.
>>The snowman's nose is a carrot!
>>What word should we underline?
>>Group and Teacher: Carrot.
>>Amanda Kuhlman: Tier two is when a
student is not seeing their potential.
They are receiving a small group
in addition to the tier one--
so outside of my classroom or with
me at a different time of the day.
>>Melanie Lyons: They're always in a
small group, usually no bigger than six,
with a teacher, with a paraprofessional.
>>Dara Dutcher: Using an
intervention, using the technology.
>>Amanda Kuhlman: Oh,
this one looks cool.
>>Dara Dutcher: Tier three
is even further intervention.
I pull them a separate
time during the day
to give them an extra
push of instruction.
>>Melanie Lyons: That is with groups
from one, two, maybe three and they get
that about three to four times a week.
>>Our b- buried...
>>Very good, Norman.
>>...deep inside the earth.
>>Brooklyn: Instead of having to
have one teacher the whole time,
then I get to go to different teachers
and experience, like, new classrooms.
It was kinda hard to learn my
schedule in the first week,
but in the second week I got it down.
>>Dara Dutcher: Okay, if you are one
of Mrs. Rickerman's friends you need
to grab your Chromes, head
on out to guided math.
>>Donna Barrier: The students
are very proud of what they do.
They feel empowered to move
from teacher to teacher.
They feel in charge of their day.
>>Heather: My oldest child struggles
in reading, so he goes with a group
of students that are like himself.
So he's not stuck in one classroom
that has twenty-two kids
with different levels.
So I think he's gonna get some
individual attention in those areas
and he doesn't have to
feel like he's out of place
because he's not at the top.
>>Amanda Kuhlman: You know, if you
see a child who is completely lost
in a general ed classroom all day
long that wears on a kid emotionally,
socially, and academically,
obviously, and with the RTI program,
they're receiving support
that's planned for them.
>>The small group I think is
helping, 'cause he feels--
>>Confident?
>>He feels confident.
>>Yeah.
>>Right. Less threatening, too.
>>It is less threatening.
>>In class he's lost.
He's just not--
>>All right.
So if you look at our sheets that
we have that show where they're at,
is there anybody that we need to adjust?
>>Dara Dutcher: We do have to
meet a lot grade-level-wise.
We have to share a lot of information.
>>Mary Krenke: Sitting down
and talking about our students
that we are concerned about, they're
tier two, they're tier three.
What can we do?
'Cause ultimately that is our goal
is to get them back on tier one.
>>Amanda Kuhlman: You
know, every three weeks
or so we might have a group of changes.
>>My A.H. is at a ten and I'm thinking
we might want to bump him to tier three.
>>Okay.
>>Our data is consistently showing
that they're making progress.
>>The other person that's in
your room, Rachel, is J.C.
>>He is reading like crazy.
>>No!
>>Yes! >Right before Christmas
break maybe moving him back
to tier one and see what he can do.
That's awesome.
>>Donna Barrier: Over the years our
special education numbers have greatly
diminished due to our RTI.
Today, we only have about four
percent of our student population
that receives special
education services.
>>Excellent.
>>You know, at the end of the year
our students really make gains
when looking at reading tests.
>>This type of programming works.